what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so one of the most requested things
after the Infinity Gauntlet here my
youtube channel was the age of Ultron
and this makes sense because next year
Avengers 2 age of Ultron comes out now
the one thing you guys also need to keep
in mind is that Avengers 2 age of Ultron
is only using the name it's not going to
be based around the story of the age of
Ultron for a few reasons one because the
age of Ultron story largely revolves
around the actions of Susan storm and
Wolverine neither of which Marvel has
the right rights to within the realm of
making movies now one thing I'd like you
guys to pay attention to as we're going
through this story is that the age of
Ultron in a lot of ways is very
reminiscent to the Days of Future past
and the reason for this is because if
you recall our discussion about Days of
Future past we had talked about how it
was a landmark story when it first came
out and it was it was a huge deal one of
the reasons why it was such a big deal
was because it gave to us this idea of a
very dark and dystopian future a very
bleak outlook which is something we
hadn't really seen before with the
crooked world in Marvel UK we had kind
of delved into alternate realities but
we hadn't really seen anything on the
scale of what we saw with the Days of
Future past and so we had talked about
how that story would influence other
stories for generations to come and the
age of Ultron is a perfect example of
that now as we get into the age of
Ultron story we're actually following
Hawkeye and initially we don't realize
it's him all we know is that in the torn
down derelict city of New York that
somebody is following what appears to be
a woman of the night as she's moving
towards an apartment building of some
kind and what we see going on here is
that it appears a few individuals have
noticed her and they ask her what it is
that she's doing here and Hawkeye takes
this time.this a moment in which they're
distracted to attack them to kill both
of the cards using his precision aim and
his arrows now this is a very big moment
for Hawkeye not necessarily because he's
killing these cards but because we start
the story off with Hawkeye Hawkeye and
Marvel Comics had largely been relegated
to a background character one of the
more notable stories involving him was
the House of M and Avengers disassembled
but again this is one of the first
we actually see Hawkeye being broken out
as a mainstage character within a Marvel
storyline and what we see is that after
these individuals these two guards are
killed that Hawkeye breaks into the
building and systematically begins
killing everybody in it and again this
is interesting here because despite the
fact that Hawkeye never really had top
billing in Marvel Comics he had always
presented himself as a person that
wasn't without mercy but it seems as
though that in this story he is that he
is cold and calculating and isn't giving
anybody a chance to escape what we also
see are a couple interesting villains
here the villain and the green jacket is
owl and the one in the gray shirt is
amber head now owl is a very interesting
villain here because he's largely a
daredevil villain and so for us to see
him in this story indicates that
whatever it is it's taking place is not
confined to any one superhero is not
confined to any one super villain
instead it's a massive crossover event
and so as we continue we see that
Hawkeye is continuing to go through and
to kill virtually anybody who opposes
him at this point we learned that the
whole reason why Hawkeye was here the
whole reason why he came to this
building is because spider-man is being
held captive here and his goal is to
attempt to free spider-man which of
course he's able to successfully do but
it seems as though Peter Parker has been
held drugged up he has been more or less
held unconscious so he's not fully of
oily aware of what's going on here or
fully um I guess in control of his
physical capabilities and so as Hawkeye
and spider-man are attempting to flee
the building there's some sort of
massive shake some kind of maybe massive
explosion outside we're not really sure
what it is but the entire building is
shaking all around them and what we
learn here is that several Ultron robots
have descended from the massive machine
hovering above New York down onto the
apartment below and again this is very
reminiscent of the Days of Future past
in the sense that we saw sentinels which
were procreating themselves more or less
maintaining this element of control of
society around them and the Ultron
robots tell everybody within the
apartment building that they have to
leave immediately that they need to exit
but what we'll see as the story
progresses
is that this isn't necessarily what the
Ultron robots intend they're not really
telling these people to exit it's simply
maybe a virtue of their programming and
what we learn is that while a countdown
is given the Ultron robots almost
immediately destroy the entire apartment
building but not before Hawkeye and
spider-man are able to escape now
Hawkeye in spider-man initially on
behalf of Hawkeye dude does what he can
to destroy these Ultron robots that he
manages to take out a couple of them but
then we learn why it is that Spiderman
was being held here now this will become
very important when we get into the
second issue of age of Ultron but what
I'll tells us is that there was some
kind of an agreement worked out between
himself and these Ultron robots and the
agreement was that as long as the owl
and his forces kept delivering
superheroes or super-powered beings to
Ultron and his forces the forces would
leave him alone but these Ultron robots
largely seem to ignore this and they
continue their destruction of the
apartment building now from here we
follow a Hawkeye and spider-man as they
attempt to go underground below Central
Park through the sewer system but almost
immediately after they arrive in the and
underground in the sewer system they're
ambushed by Luke Cage and she-hulk and
Luke Cage tells us or tells Clint Barton
that he was told not to return that when
he said he was going to leave that he
needed to stay gone but Hawkeye says
that his entire motivation here was to
rescue spider-man to bring spider-man
back now at the moment we don't know why
it was he had went on a mission to
retrieve spider-man if perhaps there was
some greater motivation behind it or if
it was simply something his basic that's
just trying to reclaim a superhero that
had been captured but we see that for
the most part he feels justified in his
actions that he doesn't regret leaving
the safety or the relative safety of
this underground bunker to travel and
try to gain spider-man but then we see
that Tony Stark arrives and she-hulk
tells Tony Stark to do whatever it is
that he needs to do and we see the Tony
Stark has some kind of device with him
now initially Tony Stark doesn't want to
use any kind of technology out in the
open and most likely this is due to the
fact that Ultron is able to detect the
use
technology somewhere in the city we're
not entirely sure but that would seem to
be the most likely reason but we see
that whatever this device is a Tony
Stark uses is apparently able to detect
whether or not individuals who have
arrived here have some kind of bug
planted in them by Ultron or if they're
even an Ultron robot itself but the
device is able to verify that both
Hawkeye and spider-man are in fact human
and they don't have any kind of tracking
devices implanted in them at this point
we transition to what appears to be a
makeshift barracks and within this
makeshift barracks there are various
superheroes who are holding up and it
seems as though maybe they're organizing
maybe they're trying to form a plan but
as the conversation progresses between
Hawkeye and Iron Man we learn that there
is no plan that there really is no idea
here in terms of what the next step
should be and that the reason why is
because the one person they're counting
on to help them make a plan the one
person they're counting on to help them
figure out what they should do next is
huddled in a corner crying with Captain
America shield completely shattered so
as we continue with issue number two of
age of Ultron I think you guys are
actually gonna find this story extremely
interesting and and well worth our
discussion because what this is going to
do is give us more of an idea of what
else going on here and this is where I
say this story was able to capitalize on
the Days of Future past because again
the Days of Future past gave us a very
very small glimpse into what life was
like in New York it was a very small
glimpse into what the future was like
but where Days of Future past gave us
this tiny window age of Ultron gives us
this massive experience this massive a
picture of just how bad off the world is
and what we see as we start with issue
number two is that we're actually in San
Francisco rather than New York and we're
picking up with some woman as she's
navigating her way through what appears
to be a completely ravaged San Francisco
and again we see various bodies strewn
everywhere and it's really just kind of
goes to indicate to us that this city
has been absolutely destroyed but what
we also see is that there are all Tron
robots that are simply just traversing
through the city and again based on what
we saw with the events in New York the
Ultron robot seemed to be just traveling
from one place to another
attempting to kill any sort of human
life form that they find and again this
is tied in to our discussion on Ultron
and if you haven't seen it of course I
would suggest that you guys go back and
watch it but with our discussion on
Ultron we had talked about how almost
immediately after Ultron was created
that he developed an insane hatred for
not only Hank Pym but for Humanity as
well and so it seems as though all these
Ultron robots exist to do is to traverse
whatever location Ultron has taken over
and to destroy any and all organic life
forms and with the actions of this woman
this is very interesting here what we
see is that she seems to have found a
location to hide at maybe hiding among
the dead which tells us that perhaps
these Ultron robots can't differentiate
between the humans who have been killed
and the humans who were alive or perhaps
she's buried herself so far under that
they're unable to penetrate the the dead
the dead humans in order to actually see
that she's alive but again once the
Ultron robots have passed she re-emerged
is from these corpses but almost
immediately after she does some
individual pulls a gun on her and so
what this man says is that he's she's
searching for something he believes that
she may have something that she's got a
car that she's got food but whatever is
that she has he demands it and she turns
around and asked him where it is that he
got this gun and what we see taking
place here is that more or less this man
while he initially starts off confident
with a gun pointed at her that the
longer this conversation goes on the
more shaken he becomes indicating to us
that this man's not nearly as confident
as he appears and this seems to be
something that this woman is able to to
pick up on she points out that this
man's a coward and she reveals herself
and what we see is that this woman is
actually Black Widow Natasha Romanoff
and that her face is disfigured now most
likely it's disfigured due to the result
of maybe some kind of conflict with the
Ultron robots or the fact that maybe
there was a firefight we don't really
know what all we do know here is that
her physical appearance has changed and
this man is a little surprised by this
he's a little caught off guard by the
fact that she's facially that their
faces is disfigured and so again as this
man is trying to get her to to hand over
whatever is a sheet has this guy isn't
turned shot in the head and initially
met Asha Romanoff doesn't really know
what to do she's kind of surprised by
this but then we see that she uses
sign language to communicate with
somebody up on a roof now we don't know
exactly who this man is at first but
what we learned is that this is marc
spector
this is moon night and so what we learn
is that for the most part it seems as
though moon night and natasha romanoff
have formed this kind of alliance where
the two of them are trying to work
together to figure out what it is is
going on or at the very least to simply
just stay alive and at this point
Natasha Romanov does really the only
thing she can which is to loot the
corpse of this man to take what he has
and to move forward Natasha Romanov and
marc spector
agreed to meet at a safe house and again
we're not exactly sure what the safe
house is but I would go as far as to
suspect that it's one of Nick Fury safe
houses
but as natasha romanoff is making her
way we see that one of the Ultron robots
is in an alleyway and appears to be
telling some individuals to to either
submit or to perish and these
individuals run for they immediately try
to bail out but as soon as they do
they're all totally incinerated they're
immediately killed off now natasha
romanoff is able to stay hidden she's
able to stay away from this and allow
this event to take place and while it
does seem I guess a little cold and
calculating it really is the only way
for her to stay alive and again this
point to just how dire the situation is
that almost immediately after any human
is spotted they're killed off by these
Ultron robots from here we pick up with
natasha romanoff as she enters some kind
of a barber shop and again this is very
I guess reminiscent of the early days in
Captain America comics when he and the
Falcon had transitioned to the basement
of a barber shop when we were at when we
had our discussion during the Infinity
Gauntlet about quasar about Wendell
Vaughn and again it seems as though
they're descending down into a safehouse
into someplace that's very well hidden
and marc spector is meeting her there
and marc spector tells her for the most
part that this situation that they're in
this place at the rim is more or less
the safest place for them to be at
there's really the safest location they
can get that every day things are
getting worse and worse that more and
more people are not are dying and so we
see that this this sort of wall has been
created or received various superheroes
who have been penned here now we don't
know exactly whether or not all these
individuals are dead or if all these
individuals are
live or if maybe some of them are dead
and some of them are alive were not a
hundred percent sure there are some
people here that we would think wouldn't
be affected by this for example the
Silver Surfer we would think that this
is largely an Earthbound event and the
Silver Surfer is largely in a beyond the
earth kind of character where he simply
only gets involved on the planet Earth
if there's some major sort of crisis
going on here but we also see people
like the wasp Luke Cage who we know is
alive the century Robert Reynolds Black
Bolt and so for the most part we're led
to believe that maybe these individuals
are alive but again this is just kind of
of up for debate here what we also
learned is that this is indeed Nick
Fury's are one of Nick Fury secret
hideouts and that while Nick Fury has a
large majority of them all around in
different locations that again this is
probably one that most people don't know
about and the reason why Natasha
Romanoff tells us this is the case is
because Nick Fury never kept things any
and never kept them written down he
never actually left a paper trail for
anybody to follow and so because of that
no one knows about this safe house
except for those individuals that Nick
Fury may have told or those individuals
who for whatever reason it's simply just
stumbled upon it now whether or not it's
possible that Ultron could find this
place by interrogating other people who
may have known where it is is something
we don't know but I would go as far as
to say that I doubt the Ultron robots
would go as far as to interrogate
somebody and then track down two humans
when it's inevitable that they would
most likely die out of starvation or a
dehydration eventually due to a lack of
resources as time goes on but from here
we transition back to a Central Park
back to Peter Parker and what we get
with Peter Parker is actually a really
cool story here Peter Parker more or
less gives us this idea of what's going
on from his perspective in the sense
that we learn how everything began to
unfold here and what Peter Parker tells
us is that this all started while he was
asleep that he was simply just in his
apartment presumably the night after
Heuer gets the day after he had spent
all night long
parading around as spider-man and
fighting various criminals here and
there but what wakes him up is this kind
of explosion this massive shift and when
he looks out the window he realized that
there's some giant machine
is tearing through New York and as
things progress as panic begins to rain
that he's trying to figure out what it
is that's going on now for the most part
this is about as in-depth as our story
with Peter Parker goes in this comic but
where Peter Parker also tells us is that
this seems to be everywhere that there
is no safe place there is no military
there's no Washington DC that everything
is gone here the other question that he
answers is a question that everybody's
asking of how it was that he was
kidnapped and why he was kidnapped and
Peter Parker says he doesn't know he
says that for the most part all he knows
is that as he was trying to figure out
what was going on as he was trying to
save various people that his spider
sense didn't even go off that some kind
of a flashbang initiated and he woke up
tied up to a chair but what he also
tells us is that he had heard some of
the guards talking some of the people
holding on to him or what it was that
they were saying and they were saying
things like they had struck a deal with
Ultron that they were going to take
people into Ultron and Ultron would in
turn leave them alone now of course the
question that everybody asks is why
wouldn't why would all try and do this
why would all Tron care about what it is
that's going on with various people or
even if you did have a desire to
eradicate humanity why is it that he
would work with people why wouldn't you
simply just eradicate them on site and
and spider-man says he doesn't know he
has no real idea what it is it's taking
place here he has no real idea why it is
that Ultron would get involved with
human with humans if what he wanted to
do was kill humans in the first place
and so from here we see this kind of
speculation taking place where various
people are trying to figure out what's
going on where various people are trying
to discuss what it is it might take
place but what we also see spider-man
saying is I guess asking is what it is
that they're going to do what the next
step is what what kind of planet is that
everybody has but what Tony Stark says
is that their only real plan is to
survive and Peter Parker says that
surviving isn't doing anything that they
have to do something and Captain America
agrees
Captain America jumps up and says that
the reason why nothing had been done was
because they didn't have a plan or at
least not until now
so as we pick up with age of Ultron
issue number three we start off with
she-hulk
and Luke Cage and it seems as though
whatever it is is going on here may be
part of the plan that was presumably
created by Captain America and again
what we see is that Luke Cage as
she-hulk if she sees anything presumably
whether or not she sees any Ultron
robots and and and she-hulk says no says
that she doesn't actually see anybody
and so what Luke Cage tells her if so
simply just brace herself to go limp and
it seems as though the reason why is
because he's going to punch her as hard
as he possibly can but if she braces
herself for the impact she's not going
to be knocked out so as long as she goes
limp and he can hit her as hard as he
can then she'll most likely fall
unconscious and so what we see is that
when this happens when Luke Cage punches
are as hard as he possibly can
that the result is that the immediate
area begins to shake due to the impact
now half of this is due to the
indestructible skin that Luke Cage has
and the incredible strength that he has
along with it and the other half is
simply just due to the sheer force of
impact against a being as strong as she
Hulk and so we see that she hoped falls
unconscious and Luke Cage picks her up
to presumably carry her back to where
all Tron is at this point we jump back
through a flashback from Luke Cage to
about an hour before we started this
story and what spider-man is saying here
is that everybody more or less just kind
of needs to suck it up that everybody
just sort of needs to get it together
and they need to go back on the
offensive and try to fight Ultron Emma
Frost replies by saying that it's just
not that easy that there are so few of
them left that they would probably be
wiped out almost immediately that
individuals like Scott Summers are gone
and we see of course that it's chimed in
that Thor is gone that the Incredible
Hulk Bruce Banner is gone and that Ben
Grimm is gone and so for the most part
the most physically powerful individuals
they have the I guess the foundation of
powerhouses that they have within the
superhero universe are gone that there's
really no way for anybody to physically
go toe-to-toe with any of the Ultron
robots and so all they really have left
on their side is their intellect is
their ability to be cunning the Spider
Man asked Luke Cage about Jessica Jones
and their newborn baby and Luke Cage
doesn't reply but we see that Luke Cage
is kind of crying to himself as he's
more or less retelling us this story
indicating that Jessica Jones and his
newborn baby were both killed in the
initial attack by Ultron from here we
see Captain America saying that things
are the way they are now because they
didn't have a plan before they didn't
have a plan before the arrival of Peter
Parker and that the idea here is to give
them something to trade is to give
Ultron something to barter with now what
we'll learn is that initially it's not
the idea to simply just barter that
Captain America has a second point to
this to this plan and Hawkeye asks him
what it is they should barter for and
spider-man continues again with a little
prodding from my Captain America to
retell what it was that he had told them
previously that the owl as spider-man
had overheard it was able to maintain
his operations they were able to
continue doing whatever was that they
were doing before as long as they made
payments to Ultron and the payments were
in the form of superheroes and so most
likely a large majority of the
superheroes or even supervillains who
had been killed were probably killed by
the owl and various other people who
were selling them off in order to keep
themselves alive and again Emma Frost
continues by saying that I'm sorry storm
continues by saying that nobody's
answering her question now the question
here is why wouldn't all Tron stantly
just kill everyone
why wouldn't all try and simply just
wipe everybody out why would he go
through all the trouble to to simply
ruin the world and Tony Stark chimes in
by saying that he knows exactly why
Ultron hasn't simply just killed
everyone and what Tony Stark gives us is
some really interesting insight into
Ultron and is probably the answer to the
question that a lot of you guys are
asking of why is it that Ultron hasn't
killed everyone what Tony Stark's tells
us is that Ultron was created to have
human needs and desires and that he
thinks that what Ultron is doing right
now is replicating what he thinks needs
and desires are so the idea of revenge
of torture someone is so forth that
these are all ideas that Ultron has
programmed himself to believe and so
he's acting out effectively the way that
he thinks a human would act out and so
he asked the question let's say that
Ultron won and that he took over the
world didn't what would happen and Emma
Frost replies by saying that it simply
just wouldn't be enough and so the idea
here is that Ultron
is more or less establishing himself as
a dictator and living out the role of a
dictator with that they're not really
sure exactly what the end result of all
this is going to be and so from here we
see that that that Hawkeye replies by
saying that this is all Hank pimp's
fault and again Tony Stark sides on with
Hank Pym here he says that it's not
necessarily Hank Penn's fault and
Hawkeye gets angry here
Hawkeye says that who else's fault would
it be that it's not the fault of anybody
else aside from Hank Pym because Hank
Pym was the one who created Ultron now
again if you recall our discussion about
Ultron we had talked about how when he
was first created by Hank Pym that
almost immediately Ultron rebelled but
then Ultron had modified the memories of
Hank Pym so that Hank Pym would never
remember the fact that he made Ultron
and so by the time Ultron had rehearsed
with Ultron number five that he was far
more advanced and he had previously been
and was an almost unstoppable force that
he could simply just be held off whether
he can never really be killed because he
would simply just reconstitute himself
in one form or another and so again more
or less what's taking place here is this
I guess intervention or this intervening
of Captain America and saying that none
of what's going on matters anymore that
none of this arguing and this debating
matters that what matters is that it's
time to make a plan that if Ultron is
buying and selling people if he is
taking trades if he has allowing people
to continue their operations as long as
they give Ultron superheroes or
super-powered beings then he says why
not just give him one of them why not
have one of them had be handed in more
or less and Wolverine chimes in and says
that that can't really get them that far
into Ultron's world but again we see I
guess this idea more or less coming to
fruition where the idea is maybe one of
them can get further inside than they
normally would that maybe one of them
would be able to get deep inside the
base of Ultron and be able to actually
influence or be able to initiate some
incredible damage here be able to
initiate some
I guess the set of circumstances more or
less swear by Ultron would could
effectively be destroyed and so we see
that again
Hawkeye chimes in and says that he
doesn't really know how successful this
would be he doesn't know how powerful an
individual would have to be in order to
actually get in there and to inflict
some damage and so what we see
Wolverines saying is that it would have
to be somebody incredibly powerful here
it would have to be somebody very very
strong somebody durable somebody's
sturdy somebody who is nigh
indestructible and so we immediately see
that she-hulk and Luke Cage volunteer
themselves in order to go in and to try
to infiltrate Ultron's base and
initially the idea is no that that that
she-hulk should be the one to do it
but again Luke Cage says that he has an
indestructible skin he has the the
ability more or less to not be killed
but again the she-hulk says that she's
the stronger of the two now what's very
interesting about this entire set of
circumstances here and something that I
hope you picked up is that Maria Hill is
part of the team here Maria Hill is part
of these forces she's part of this
superhero group or this group of
individuals who are trying to stay alive
and what this more or less tells us is
that the idea of enemies the idea of
allies isn't really something that
exists here is people who were simply
just trying to live and so again we see
that Emma Frost uses her ability to read
the mind of others and tell everybody
that Tony Stark is going to say that
it's not going to work that this is not
going to to be successful that neither
of them are going and Tony Stark says
yes he says that this is only half a
plan that it's not a full plan and that
it's not worth the life of another
person but then we see she hooked over
ruling him by simply saying that she's
not going to just sit around that the
idea of waiting to die is worse than
simply going out and doing something
that may result in them dying and so she
wanted to do something she wants to get
involved somehow and she wants to be the
one that breaks into Ultron's fortress
and so Luke 8 says okay and says that
he'll be the one that'll take her but
Wolverine says no Wolverine says that he
should be the one to take she-hulk but
then we see Captain America saying that
this would be a ridiculous thing to do
because
Wolverine has adamantium laced skin and
that automatically bones rather and that
Ultron would immediately take Wolf's
rank he wouldn't even allow Wolverine to
be to hand she-hulk over that he would
take Wolverine and he would dissect
Wolverine and uses adamantium possibly
even try to find a way to replicate it
and use it for his own means and so
somebody else needs to go along somebody
that can hand she Hulk over and then
walk away and so the idea here is that
they're going to stick with Luke Cage
that Luke Cage is going to be the one to
hand she Hulk over to Ultron from here
we see them trying to decide where to go
next that because they're going to be
leaving the space that they can't come
back here and so Captain America says
they should go to the mutate village in
Savage Land
and that for the most part while he
believes that it's not necessarily been
conquered by Ultron that the possibility
remains but that that's a possibility
that they're going to have to take a
gamble on and so we see that again
she-hulk and Luke Cage set out to
complete this plan that's been laid out
by Captain America at this point we pick
up with Luke Cage as he's as his caring
she-hulk back to Ultron's base and as
Luke Cage approaches the the base
several Ultron robots arrive and Luke
Cage says that he has a Hulk and that he
wants to trade from here we transition
to Chicago and when we pick up with
Chicago we see the some individual is
more or less detecting the fact that the
air is poison here that the air is most
likely irradiated now this is probably
due to maybe some kind of nuclear
devastation some kind of nuclear fallout
we don't really know but we learned that
of the individuals who were here that
we're currently seeing black panther
Thunderbolt Ross as Red Hulk and the
taskmaster and again the taskmasters
involvement here more or less tells us
that there really are no no enemies here
that really are no villains here that is
simply just people trying to survive and
so what we see a task master observing
is that there is an Ultron robot down on
the that amount on a half away alongside
some individual some kind of human now
whether or not this is a super-powered
being is something we don't know but we
see that Thunderbolt Ross immediately
takes off and goes after this Ultron
robot which appears to have been the
plan
now why it is he's doing this is
something we don't know but we learned
that during the conflict or I guess
during the fight between Thunderbolt
Ross and his Ultron robot that he tears
the robots head off and with the robots
head comes what appears to be a kind of
makeshift spinal cord and the intention
as it's explained to us seems to be that
black panther and tag man a taskmaster
are going to use this head of Ultron to
perhaps try to find some way to defeat
the other Ultron robots were even Ultron
itself and so for the most part we see
that while Thunderbolt Ross is
overwhelmed by the arrival of other
Ultron robots that had a taskmaster and
black panther
immediately run for it at the behest of
a Thunderbolt Ross to leave him behind
from this point we transitioned back to
New York with Luke Cage and and she-hulk
and Luke Cage is heading back into the
major fortress right gets into the main
base of Ultron which apparently resides
within Times Square and once he actually
gets inside of the building we learn a
very disturbing fact what we learn here
is that it's not in fact Ultron that's
running the show that it is in fact
vision now we don't know exactly at this
moment why it is that vision is here or
why vision is the one that's actually
taking the place of Ultron that'll
actually be something that's explained
to us an age of Ultron issue number four
so as we continue with age of Ultron
issue number four we again pick up with
Luke Cage as he realizes that the vision
is actually occupying this current point
within the Ultron city that it's not
actually Ultron who's here now at the
moment we don't know if Ultron is the
one that's controlling everything
through vision or if it's actually the
vision who has somehow gone awry and is
controlling everything but what the
vision asks Luke Cage is what it is that
he has to offer and Luke Cage a skull or
ask the vision if he's the one that did
all this if he's the one that he's
talking to and vision says that Ultron
can hear him that Ultron can see Luke
Cage and for the most part Luke Cage
doesn't really know what to make of this
luke cage's is a little unsure and he
again asks where it is that Ultron is at
presuming that Ultron may very well be
in a different city or perhaps out in
space or something like that but what
the vision tells us is that Ultron isn't
even in this current
time that Ultron is actually in the
future that he's controlling everything
from the future he's controlling these
Ultron robots and he is to a degree
controlling the vision now the vision
says this of his own accord indicating
to us that Ultron is really more I guess
using the vision more of like a window
to control the past more so than
outright controlling the vision and so
the vision seems to be used simply as a
conduit for Ultron to control the past
and what that what the vision says once
I guess Ultron regains control of him is
too is asking again Luke Cage what it is
that he has to offer but she Hulk has
overheard enough at this point she
realizes that there's really only one
Road from this point and so what she
does is tell Luke Cage to get out of
here and to tell Tony Stark everything
he's overheard from here Luke Cage is a
little surprised by this and Luke Cage
is actually reluctant to leave and so
she Hulk throws him out of the building
from this point she Hulk again goes on a
tangent and says that she's that she
believes that she's almost the strongest
one there is as she begins to to defeat
or I guess to tear apart these various
forms of the Ultron robots but just as
she's beginning to gain the upper hand
one of the Ultron robots is able to
shoot her in the side of the head with a
laser beam and effectively kill her from
this point we see the vision is a little
disheartened to realize that she's dead
and that he really is helpless to stop
any of this from happening and so as
Luke Cage is being I guess is landing
after his throw from the building the
Ultron robots begin to pursue him and
again because Luke Cage has
indestructible skin there really isn't a
whole lot they can do to defeat him and
so Luke Cage begins to take out his rage
and aggression on them he tells them
that they killed his wife that they
killed his baby that they killed his
friends but as Luke Cage is again
preparing to try to defeat these Ultron
robots that it appears at what's taking
place is a nuclear blast over New York
City now we don't know exactly whether
or not Luke Cage survives this nuclear
blast yet all we know is that at this
point there's been a massive explosion
within the the immediate vicinity of
downtown Manhattan from here we pick up
with marc spector and natasha romanoff
and what natasha romanoff is telling us
here is that she was able to open the
black box that they were previously
unable to open
and that within this black box are
Fury's nick fury's into the world
scenarios one of which is a situation in
which Ultron was able to take over the
world
and the question the mark Spector is
asking here is what are they supposed to
do what's supposed to happen next
natasha romanoff says that Nick Fury had
a series of secret bunkers all over the
world and that one of the bunkers was
designed to be an end-of-the-world
bunker and that this end-of-the-world
bunker is located in the Savage Land
indicating to us that both the forces of
Captain America as well as Natasha
Romanov and marc spector will most
likely all end up meeting together
within the savage land proper at this
point we transition to eight days later
and what we see is that the forces of a
Captain America's team have arrived in
the Savage Land but rather than finding
a Savage Land which may very well have
been free from the destruction of
Ultron's forces they instead father
savage land has been riddled with
destruction there are various potholes
and they appear to be nuclear explosions
around various portions of the of the
area and again they found a jet here a
Avengers jet the question they have is
who it was that fluid here and how it
landed or who it was it did this again
The Invisible Woman is keeping them
invisible for the most part so they're
trying to do what they can to decipher
what it is is taking place before going
further because for all they know it
could very well be another Ultron robot
or some other third party they're
unaware of who is somehow managed to
land and establish land but as they're
investigating the area they realize that
there is a man on the hilltop and when
they reach this hilltop they realized
that it's kazar the lord of the Savage
Land
now kazar is a character that we haven't
necessarily gotten into yet for a good
reason that reason being because for the
most part he's not a wildly important
character and the realm of Marvel Comics
at the moment he's more important back
in the 90s but for this point he's
really not a major player in this story
but what he tells us is that when
Ultron's forces began to overrun the
world when they began to take over that
they invaded everywhere which included
the Savage Land and that what's left
these various huts in this small little
village is all this left of of khazars
people of the various people spread
across the Savage Land who have managed
to come together to try to keep
themselves safe but he also tells them
that within
of these huts is what it is they're
looking for Emma Frost uses her a
telepathic abilities and realizes that
within this Hut is Luke Cage and that
Luke Cage had piloted the Avengers jet
that they had found and apparently had
been irradiated due to the fallout from
the nuclear explosion that he's alive
but that none of them need to go in
there and see him most likely indicating
that he's a grotesquely disfigured as a
result of his exposure to the nuclear
blast and she tells us that Luke Cage
after the explosion had crawled to to
safety had managed to make it into the
jet and then crawled to this village
within the Savage Land and what Luke
Cage tells Emma Frost telepathically is
that Ultron is not in this current time
that Ultron is in the future and then in
order for them to defeat Ultron they're
going to have to find a way to travel to
the future and so again we see that this
is this idea this question becomes what
are they going to do next what's going
to happen next and as the group is
trying to figure this out we see
somebody else try man and say that
they're going to get Ultron at this
point we switched to Red Hulk and Red
Hulk says they're going to eliminate
Ultron from the face of existence that
this what we learned that who also is
here is Mark Spectre moon night along
with Natasha Romanov then Natasha
Romanoff tells them that because they
discovered Nick Fury's uh I guess into
the world scenario files because they
discovered the location of his end of
the world bunker that they know exactly
how it is that they're going to have to
kill Ultron so as we pick up with age of
Ultron issue number five there are a
couple things we need to clarify the
reason why is because this story is
going to become relatively confusing in
a very fast pace now the whole basis for
this age of Ultron story is that the
Ultron forces oh I guess these various
Ultron robots have successfully
conquered the planet Earth and at the
beginning of this story we didn't know
how all we had really known is that they
had simply just appeared and began
destroying various cities it wasn't
until the last issue or I guess until
issues number three and four that we
learned that what appeared to be the
case was that the vision was maybe
controlling these robots but what the
vision had informed us was that Ultron
in the future was controlling these
robots and so what had basically taken
place is that Ultra
had used the vision as a conduit and
what this means is that the vision is
more or less an open window from the
future into the present and so what
Ultron did is by virtue of manipulating
the vision he created this window he
established this window that allowed him
to speak from the future into his past
which is the current timeline or the
current set of circumstances in the
Marvel or in this comic but what we see
as the story begins to open up here is
that the superheroes are making their
way to Nick Fury's bunker and Tony
begins to more or less comment on this
Tony Stark begins to I guess comment on
their current situation and saying that
this is all funny to him in a very dark
and humorous kind of way and the reason
why was because when the vision had
first showed up the vision was an agent
of Ultron and so they didn't really know
if they could trust the vision or not
but the vision had turned against Ultron
and helped the Avengers defeat Ultron
and so because of this the Avengers
simply just welcomed the vision and the
Scarlet Witch eventually married the
vision they had befriended the vision
and while they had treated the vision
like a human the fact remained that the
vision was not the vision was a robot
and so they didn't understand the
technology that was used by Ultron to
create the vision they really had no
understanding of the vision and so it
could very well be that there was a
subroutine implanted in the vision
somewhere along the line that would
allow Ultron to alter his programming or
to take control of the vision that would
allow the vision to become a conduit for
Ultron to manipulate the past from the
future but again Tony Stark's more or
less just talking to himself here he's
more or less just providing this
commentary for himself and the reason
why is because a lot of the other
superheroes are more or less assuming
that Tony Stark has kind of lost his
mind and so we see that Captain America
is doing what he can to keep everybody's
morale up to keep everybody focused on
the current objective which is to reach
Nick Fury's bunker from here we see that
they are they arrived at the bunker
they're currently at its location but
again they're very wary here and the
reason why they're so wary is because
they don't know what's on the other side
they don't know what's within the bunker
it could very well be that Ultron was
aware of this bunker because it was in
the future and
had planted a multitude of Ultron robots
inside and that once the door is opened
these robots would come pouring out and
annihilate all of these superheroes and
so he initially calls on Emma Frost but
Emma says that the basis or I guess the
the fortitude of this compound is such
that she can't access it using her
telepathy she doesn't know what's within
this this bunker he then calls on
Wolverine and Wolverine says it to him
it just smells like a jungle again
commenting that he doesn't know what's
on the other side but what Emma Frost
says is that she doesn't like this that
if the bunker was built to keep
telepaths out then that means that it
could be that on again on the other side
of this bunker our Ultron robots we then
see that that Captain America calls on
on Susan storm and asks Susan storm if
she can use her invisibility to get
closer to the entrance without being
detected and when she does she realizes
two things that one there's some kind of
a Quixote code here there's some kind of
a keypad that has to be used to access
this giant door but the other thing is
that this door doesn't necessarily seem
to be something that can easily be
destroyed that none of the superheroes
as it appears would be able to tear this
door down now initially Captain America
calls on spider-man here and ask
spider-man if he senses any kind of a
danger but spider-man says that his
power doesn't work that way that his
spider sense is reactionary that he
himself has to be in danger in order for
him to actually order for his spider
sense to actually go off and so he uses
the only option left to him which is
Thunderbolt Ross the Red Hulk and so
what the Red Hulk does is used his vast
strength his incredible strength to
punch down the door which of course we
had previously believed was something
that just couldn't be done but what we
see almost immediately after he enters
and the other superheroes begin to make
their way in is that he is pelted by a
barrage of bullets and the bullets
appear to be the kind that may not
necessarily kill Thunderbolt Ross but at
the very least are possibly able to
injure him and what we learn is that the
person that shooting Thunderbolt Ross
with all these bullets is in fact Nick
Fury himself telling us that Nick Fury
has yet again managed to find a way to
survive against all
because despite the fact that Nik theory
is an established shield agent despite
the fact that he is the director of
shield in the end Nick Fury is just a
man that he could be killed just like
anybody else and that the Infinity
formula as we had previously talked
about our Nick Fury videos only goes as
far as enabling to him enabling him to
survive the I guess the aspect of dying
of old age and so what Nick Fury says
here is that before any of them enter
the bunker that he's going to use some
kind of scanning device to make sure
that they are in fact who they claim to
be that they're not Ultron robots
disguised as humans and so once he's
satisfied with this once he realizes
that all of them are in fact who they
claim to be he allows them into the
bunker and from what from this point
when Nick Fury tells us is that he's
been here for about a week or so that
he's surprised that it took these
superheroes to get here this long but
they say that they didn't even know this
bunker was here they were totally
unaware of it that it wasn't until till
black Black Widow and marc spector had
arrived that they had learned that this
bunker was actually in existence and
what Nick Fury says is that he had built
this bunker after the scroll invasion
after the secret invasion
now the secret invasion is again a story
we haven't gotten into yet this was a
story that had taken place after Civil
War but the secret invasion was a story
whereby the scrolls were invading the
planet Earth and replicating various
superheroes and humans and so Nick Fury
knowing that he couldn't really trust
anybody had designed this bunker so that
if things went from bad to worse or some
extreme measure had to be taken that he
would be able to do that and this
extreme measure is actually revealed to
us by by Tony Stark what we learn is
that this bunker is not just a bunker
that this bunker is more or less doctor
dooms time platform now again doctor
dooms time platform is not something
that we've talked about yet because we
haven't really gotten into Doctor Doom
but the time platform is exactly what it
sounds like it allows individuals to
travel through time and so again this is
we're gonna be seeing these superheroes
manipulate the concept of time what Nick
Fury also says is that he believes that
Ultron is in the future which is
something that we were already aware of
but what he says is that the idea here
the
the entire basis of this plan was
something that wasn't necessarily
contingent on the superheroes that he
was going to give them a few more days
whether if they didn't show up that he
was going to go on its assignment by
himself
and so we see that for the most part
various superheroes begin to chime in
and begin to volunteer themselves of
course marc spector moon knight
volunteers along with Black Widow but we
see the Nick Fury's telling them that
he's going to need more than two of them
that the plan is to go directly to where
Ultron is at two interests fortress and
to effectively just annihilate him but
it's not going to be something that can
be done with sheer force that it's going
to require both a lot of stealth and a
lot of firepower and then he has a lot
of technology to go with it the Tony
Stark is against this Tony Stark
rationalizes that if Ultron is in the
future then this current moment is
Ultron's past and so if this is Ultron's
past an Ultron knows what's going to
happen here he knows what road they're
going to take and so he knows that
they're going to attempt to arrive at
his fortress and they're going to
attempt to destroy him and so he's going
to be prepared for it but Quicksilver
chimes in and says that it's their only
real hope it's the only real opportunity
they have but then Wolverine chimes in
and Wolverine says this is not
necessarily the case
Wolverine rationalizes here that Hank
Pym was the one who created Ultron and
that they could go back in time if they
wanted to and they could kill Hank Pym
before he ever created Ultron now
initially this idea is almost
immediately turned down by everyone
everyone says that this can't be done
that if they went back and killed Hank
Pym before he made Ultron that they
would be killing him for something that
he hadn't done yet they'd be killing an
innocent man but not only that they'd be
killing a friend and so the
ramifications of this are something that
they can't even begin to understand that
if Hank Pym doesn't exist what would the
future look like
what could possibly happen things could
turn out almost exactly the way they are
now what they could turn out far darker
than they currently are or they could
turn out much better than they are the
fact remains no one knows what would
happen to the entire space-time
continuum if this action took place and
so this idea of Wolverines is almost
immediately shot down this is almost not
going to happen no one is really on the
side
this and so what Nick Fury does is that
he says that while everybody else is
trying to figure out what they want to
do he unlocks this kind of vault this
more or less weapons cache and when he
does we see a multitude of arms and
armament belonging to various either
dead or alive superheroes that may have
handed their stuff over to Nick Fury of
course we see Magneto's helmet we see
the mark to from from Iron Man's past
which of course was a very primitive
Iron Man armor and is one that's not
tapped into any kind of network and so
Ultron wouldn't be able to take over
this suit we see of course various
things like Hawkeye Zaros and so on and
so forth but what's explained to us here
is that all these things are going to
need to be used all these things are
going to have to be used for the purpose
of invading Ultron's fortress but again
we see that most of these superheroes
are a little hesitant here
most of these superheroes while they are
very interested in defeating Ultron at
the very least have these very subtle
unsure I guess motives or feelings
they're a little nervous about what's
going to take place but none of them are
really backing out and so once they
realized where the coordinates are going
to be once they realize where it is
they're going to arrive and what it is
that they're going to do most all the
superheroes onboard and so what we see
is that as a time platform begins to
activate Quicksilver says that if they
don't make it back I'm sorry have mixed
review says they don't make it back that
they're supposed to burn this place down
they're supposed to destroy the entire
bunker and so we see the superheroes
begin to I guess travel into the future
by a virtue of this platform but almost
immediately after most of the
superheroes jump into the future we see
that Wolverine asks Peter Parker if he
knows how to manipulate this time
platform then Peter Parker says that I
asked him if whether or not he wants to
chase after him but what Wolverine says
is that he wants to go back into the
past that he wants to go back and he
wants to kill Hank Pym Peter Parker is
almost immediately against this but
Wolverine says that in a very
interesting kind of a situation here
that there really is no hope for the
forces of Nick Fury that the Ultron
forces had killed for they had killed
the thing they'd killed Luke Cage they'd
killed some of the strongest superheroes
and so for those superheroes to attempt
to go back for red hope to go back along
with others that there really wouldn't
be anything they could do to stop the
forces of Ultron on us so the only real
option here is for them to go back into
the past and for them to kill Hank Pym
so as we get into age of Ultron issue
number six we're gonna be seeing this
really really cool story playing out
because what's gonna happen is we're
gonna transition between the future and
the past but what we're gonna learn are
a couple things the first is we're gonna
learn exactly how bleak the future is
but we're also going to learn is what
happens when you go into the past and
you make changes that just because one
action takes place doesn't necessarily
mean that there are not going to be
massive ramifications and in fact we're
actually going to learn that the the
actions of Wolverine here are going to
stretch far beyond the age of Ultron
story and is actually going to be used
by Marvel to introduce characters later
on down the line there's going to be
used to introduce characters from other
alternate realities into the Marvel
Universe although of course that'll take
place beyond the scope of the age of
Ultron event but what we see as we start
this story is of course that Wolverine
has used doctor dooms time platform and
is emerging from where the bunker would
have been in its geographical location
but of course he's in the past here and
what he does is for the most part just
explore the immediate area of the Savage
Land the immediate area of the cave to
ensure that everything's okay to make
sure that there's no trap going on here
that the Ultron robots aren't present
that there's no I guess excavation or
investigation or the presence of anyone
that isn't supposed to know that he's
there but as he's moving around he
realizes that he's not alone and so what
he tells this person is to show
themselves and what we learn is that the
person that's followed him is Susan
storm now initially Susan storm was
supposed to join Nick Fury's team in the
future as they attempted to enter the
base of Ultron and to defeat Ultron but
she had stayed behind and when Wolverine
asked her about this she says that she
had a change of heart when she saw that
Wolverine wanted to kill Hank Pym
the look that he had in his eye was a
look to indicate that he would not be a
swage that he would not be moved from
this mindset and so as soon as Captain
America who had told him not to go into
the past had left with Nik theory to go
into the future
she knew that Wolverine was going to try
to use the the platform to travel into
the past and try to kill Hank Pym and so
what she does and what her and Wolverine
get involved with is this really cool
debate this really cool discussion that
is logic versus morality and this is one
of the best parts of the age of Ultron
event because what she's saying here is
that this is a moral problem that
Wolverine is encompassing that Wolverine
is representing here Wolverine is taking
the stance that in order to more or less
save lives that a person has to die and
she initially again says that she knows
this is wrong that in her heart of
hearts she can't say that this is
something okay to do but then Wolverine
replies by saying that if somebody put a
gun to one of her children's head would
she kill them would she do whatever she
needed to do to save their lives
and initially she's a little hesitant to
answer but Wolverine says that of course
she would and of course she would kill
whoever it was that was trying to harm
her children
Wolverine says that this is more or less
the same thing but that it involves
countless people and so for Wolverine
this is a logical stance this is more or
less this utilitarian stance that in
order to satisfy the needs of the many
that the few are going to have to die
and so for Wolverine again this is very
simple one man Hank Pym created Ultron
and because he created Ultron the future
has turned out the way that it has and
so he rationalizes that if he goes back
and kills one man he can save billions
of people and so initially again Susan
storm hasn't necessarily sided with this
but she is somewhat understanding of his
opinion somewhat understanding of his
stance even if only insofar that she
recognizes she would still have her
children and her family if Hank Pym
wasn't alive
but before either of them can debate any
further there seems to be some kind of
disturbance coming closer towards where
they're located at and what we see is
that a very young version of Nick Fury
has arrived here in its hover car and of
course this seems to be around the time
that Nick Fury has discovered this
bunker or discovered this location which
may be an optimal play
for him to build the bunker we don't
really know why he's here yet this is
simply just a chance for Marvel to
introduce a way for them to gain some
sort of transportation to the city which
of course is what they do when they
steal the vehicle of Nick Fury when Nick
Fury comes out of course he finds his
vehicle gone and Wolverine and Susan's
storm make their way back to to New York
City now at this point we transition to
the future and what we see is that
Quicksilver along with the other forces
of Nick Fury have arrived and wherever
this place happens to be which is
revealed to us to be the Savage Land but
rather than finding a place that is
devoid of any and all kind of life a
place that has been absolutely ravaged
like what we had seen before they had
travelled into the future we instead see
a Savage Land that is much better off a
Savage Land that appears to be pristine
in its nature then of course you have a
various I guess dinosaurs flying around
you have a very clean and a very
beautiful sort of environment and they
find this a little strange here they
didn't expect this they expected that
everything was going to be totally
trashed and everything was going to be
totally destroyed and so we see that as
they're trying to figure things out that
Captain America realizes somebody is
gone and of course Nick Fury realizes
this as well and Iron Man comments and
says that the susan's storm was supposed
to be with them Nick Fury at this point
gets very angry and the reason why is
because Susan storm was supposed to be
their stealth component she was supposed
to be the person to sneak in but again
iron man comments and says that it
really wouldn't have done any good to
have had Susan storm here and the reason
why is because while she can be
invisible that Ultron most likely has
some kind of thermal imaging program set
up and so the cameras would have
immediately detected her body heat they
wouldn't have been able to they would
have been able to see her and so it
really wouldn't have made any sense to
have her around but again Nick Fury says
that this is supposed to be a black-bag
mission this is supposed to be a black
ops mission and that people just simply
can't go rogue and so what he tells
Quicksilver is to scout the area to
travel to New York City and to try to
find whatever he can to inform them what
it is it's taking place we also see him
calling on storm to give them some mode
of transportation and to have earthquake
make sure that there's nothing that
would attack
in the immediate vicinity of course
using her powers to create earthquakes
to shell off any kind of foe that would
attempt to attack them we also see him
calling on Red Hulk on Thunderbolt Ross
and telling him that he's going to be
the backup for earthquake so that if
there are some measure of forces that
are beginning to overwhelm her that he
can jump in and he can attempt to
overthrow those forces as well at this
point we transition back to Susan storm
and Wolverine of course again they're in
the past in the 1960s I would go as far
as to say and what they were doing here
is again investigating the area but for
Susan storm this is very weird for her
of course Wolverine comments and says
that he thought the Fantastic Four had
time traveled on multiple occasions Oh
Susan storm says that's the case but
that she's never time traveled back into
her own past and presumably landed on
her own front door this is something
that she's not used to and so what we
see is that as soon as they land that
Wolverine has picked up the scent of a
Hank be him and the two of them begin to
track this scent back to its origin at
this point we realized that hank pym is
experimenting on dragon man and again
dragon man is a character that had been
created or introduced to Marvel Comics
is kind of what you saw back in that
period of time where you saw these sort
of hokey or somewhat interesting kind of
villains as opposed to villains that
were more down-to-earth that were more
basic and human in nature and what he's
doing is more or less just analyzing
dragon man he's really just looking at
what it is is taking place here
performing various experiments trying to
understand the technology that went into
creating him but as he's trying to
figure this out Wolverine arrives and
Wolverine says that Hank hem is the
reason for the end of the future he's
the reason why everything has gone south
and of course Hank Pym is a little
overwhelmed here Hank Pym doesn't
realize what's going on he doesn't know
what's taking place and he asked
Wolverine who he is
Wolverine introduces himself by saying
that he's the ghost of Christmas future
that he's the one that's going to
correct the mistakes that Hank Pym had
made but that he knows that Hank pan
even if he's told don't create Ultron is
going to create Ultron anyway not
necessarily because he wasn't told to
but because he's curious to see what
would happen if he did and so Wolverine
rationalizes that there is no way out of
this situation for Hank Pym there's no
way for Hank Pym to survive this and so
he's decided that he is going to be the
one as
going to kill hank pym from this point
we travel back to the future and what we
see is Nick Fury Nick Fury's forces
arrive is that the entire eastern
seaboard has been converted into some
form of machinery that everything that
the entire area is for the most part
devoid of life now we don't know if the
entire planet is devoid of any kind of
human life or if the entire planet it
houses some measure of human life
although they may be hiding out in
various locations but what Tony Stark
comments here is that despite the fact
that this is a very bleak outlook
despite the fact that this is a very
dark future with regards to humanity and
the fact that all humanity may very well
have been eradicated by Ultron that the
entire landscape here the entire I guess
machined a series of machine structures
here is something he finds to be very
beautiful but almost immediately after
the superheroes arrive here the invading
forces of Ultron begin to I guess we can
do attack them and of course earthquake
uses her powers to manipulate
earthquakes to stave off a vast portion
of these of these BOTS and of course Red
Hulk himself is able to assist her as
well but then we see that in the
background more forces or arriving and
this is what happens with the
superheroes Nick Fury's team as
Wolverine had told us had no real chance
here that Ultron knew they were coming
and that Ultron would have prepared
defenses but even then the superheroes
admit they weren't really prepared for
this kind of a situation they didn't
believe that they would end up in a
scenario whereby there was no human life
whatsoever and that the entire planet
may most likely have been inhabited by
the forces of Ultron and so for the most
part the Ultron robots again continued
their overwhelming barrage on the
superheroes and from this point we
transitioned back to the past and we see
the Wolverine is attacking Hank Pym he's
attending to kill Hank Pym but as he's
trying to kill him he's explaining
things to him he's talking to him he
tells Hank Pym that of course he knows
that he did good in the world that he
did some great things but in this
instance the one act of creating Ultron
outweighs any great thing he did because
creating Ultron led to such a bleak
future it led to such a terrible
situation but as he's preparing to deal
the killing blow to a Hank Pym Susan
storm arrives
and Susan storm says that they can't do
this that they can't kill hank pym that
killing hank pam could very well have
consequences that none of them are
prepared for from this point we switch
back to the future again and we see that
all these superheroes on Nick theories
team are being completely overwhelmed by
Ultron's forces we of course see that
storm is killed we see that various
superheroes are doing the best they can
but in the end there's really nothing
they can do due to the sheer number of
Ultron robots we also transition back to
Susan storm and Wolverine and Wolverine
rationalizes that again that Hank Pan by
virtue of his actions killed everybody
and so again Susan storm says that there
has to be some kind of a line here there
has to be some Road that they don't
cross somewhere where they say that
there's a difference between them and
those that would go to the extremes to
achieve their own goals from here we
transition back to the future again and
this is what we see we see this bouncing
back and forth between the past and the
future and we see that Wolverine as he's
trying to kill Hank Pym as he's making
his argument to kill Hank hem that we're
seeing various superheroes dying for
example Captain America is had his head
blown off Nick Fury of course is being
overwhelmed and again Wolverine is
saying that everything that's turned out
the way that it has has done so because
of the actions of Hank Pym and this is
when Susan storm begins to acquiesce she
begins to give in and she realizes that
so many people that billions of people
are dead because of what Hank Pym had
done that billions of people are dead
because of what it is that he had
thought up and so while Hank Pym is
initially surprised to see that Susan
storm is giving in that eventually he's
killed by Wolverine so as we continue
our story on the age of Ultron I'm very
excited to bring you guys to issue
number seven and the reason why is
because this is going to give us a
really cool depiction of what the world
is like without Hank Pym now for the
most part we actually haven't really
seen a world like this before we've seen
versions of it we've seen variants of
what it would be like without a
character for example with Charles
Xavier having being killed by Legion we
saw the Age of Apocalypse and with the
house of M we saw The Scarlet Witch
warping reality but what we're gonna see
for the most part
it was a very dark in a very dystopian
future and it's really not like anything
that we've seen to this point because
we're going to see some very interesting
depictions of characters that we are
quite familiar with but as we continue
with this story we see that of course
Susan storm and Wolverine are headed
back to dr. Doom's time platform and of
course again they're going to be using
this platform to travel from the past
back to the present and for the most
part the Susan storm is very curious
about what's taking place she's very
unsure of things for her that she feels
as though they've crossed some line that
they can't come back from and Wolverine
tells her that she was told to wait in
the car but the fact that she chose to
appear when Wolverine was getting ready
to kill Hank hem and the fact that she
didn't stop will rain from killing Hank
Pam means that as far as Wolverine is
concerned she's just as guilty as he is
at this point we transitioned back to
the present where Wolverine and Susan
storm have arrived and what we see
taking place is that the Savage Land is
much different than they had previously
seen where in the normal timeline when
Ultron had taken over the present they
had left the Savage Land which had a
litany of potholes and markers to
indicate that a conflict had taken place
there we see that now the Savage Land
appears to be some massive area housing
a series of different kinds of ships
then again a Susan storm and and
Wolverine aren't sure what to make of
this they really don't know what to do
about this and so Susan storm makes both
Wolverine and herself invisible and they
transition down or I guess they moved
down to the to the ground level to
investigate what's going on what we also
see is that there appear to be various
individuals who are perhaps digging or
the very least maybe trying to recover
some some various forms of relics but we
also see there are a couple guards down
here now the guards refer to themselves
as start guard security indicating that
perhaps whatever it is that they're
doing here is done at the behest of Tony
Stark but we also get a little bit of
explanation here at the very least what
passes for explanation and Susan storms
hypothesis and Susan storm believes that
because of the fact that they've
discovered a skull belonging to one of
the scrolls because of the fact that
some of these ships are of scroll origin
and Kree origin that
perhaps the kree-skrull war did not go
the way that it had in the normal Marvel
timeline and what I mean by this is of
course the Korean the scroll had been
warring for quite some time and the
planet Earth was a strategic location it
was really a major point within the
conflict between the Kree in the scroll
but during the more what the normal
timeline the Avengers had helped to
stave off the conflict from coming to
the planet Earth and this is one of the
reasons why Wolverine is unaware of the
crease world war but it appears as
though in this timeline where Hank Pym
doesn't exist that the kree-skrull war
was not stopped or at the very least it
was not kept from coming to the planet
Earth and so from here we see that again
Susan storm and and Wolverine are not
necessarily panicking here but at the
very least are trying to figure out
what's going on and so they take Nick
Fury's I guess hover car and they travel
back to New York City but once they
arrived to New York they see that the
city isn't necessarily totally destroyed
but at the very least it's a shadow of
its former self in the sense that a lot
of the buildings appear to have Saints
attained some kind of damage or at the
very least they're simply beginning to
rot away or beginning to fall apart into
a state of decay what they also see is a
multitude of shield helicarrier's that
are maybe observing the city or the very
least probably trying to keep the city
safe again we don't really know here but
Susan storm questions that she asked the
question what is it that they've done
what is it that's happened here as a
result of a Hank Pym being killed off
before they can investigate to much
further their hover car is shot down at
this point we of course again see them
trying to figure out what's going on
trying to understand what's taking place
and will reign as he asked Susan storm
what it is that shot them down or
perhaps where it came from
Susan storm replies by saying that that
she doesn't know that she has no idea
where that shot came from but before
again they can investigate too much
further a voice seems to chime in and
ask him what it is that they think that
they're doing here at this point it's
revealed to us that the Avengers
apparently don't exist anymore and that
in place of the Avengers we now have the
defenders and the defenders again was a
group that was largely formed under dr.
strange in the normal
marvel universe but the group was not
necessarily on the same level as the
Avengers but it seems that it in this
reality that it is what we also see is a
change in line up from the defenders
wear during the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline we saw the defenders composed
of Doctor Strange The Incredible Hulk
Namor the Submariner and others instead
we have what appears to be Captain
America with an eyepatch as well as
Peter quill Jan Van Dyne who's wearing
Miss Marvel's uniform The Incredible
Hulk of one-eyed Cyclops and the
alternate reality version of Wolverine
now what we're going to be doing for the
sake of this discussion is we're going
to be referring to the alternate reality
version of Wolverine as just that as the
alternate reality version of himself but
in order to differentiate between him
and the other version of Wolverine we're
going to refer to the one from the
normal timeline as a normal wolf range
just as just so that we can keep things
easy to understand without things
getting too convoluted but we also see
and what's really interesting here is
that the thing is part of the defenders
but the thing is very surprised to see
Susan storm because for some reason she
may not exist in this timeline or at the
very least may have simply just vanished
from here because of the fact that they
don't really know what's going on that
they assume that the normal version of
Wolverine and Susan storm are Scrolls
and so the intention of the defenders is
to capture them now initially the idea
of the Incredible Hulk is to pummel them
to absolutely smash them but Doctor
Strange tells The Incredible Hulk to
hold on and of course
Captain America tells everybody to start
talking he tells the normal version of
Wolverine and Susan storm to explain but
again for the most part what's also yes
intriguing and this is something that we
haven't necessarily touched on is that
Jan van dyne chimes in and says that
perhaps this is some sort of trick at
the hands of Morgana lafay now we
haven't talked about Morgana lafay and
Marvel Comics and the reason why is
because for the most part she's an
adversary of Spider Woman Doctor Doom
and various other people but she's not a
very very big character she's not one
that gets top billing but because of the
fact that she is a major player in this
story it really changes things
it is really Marvel more or less taken
Morgana lafay and elevating her to an
mainstream character in addition we see
that of course the thing says that he
hasn't seen Susan storm in years and
this is going to be a major part of Ben
Grimm as he is trying to figure out
what's going on and operating as part of
the defenders in the sense that for
whatever reason for whatever it is this
happened here Susan storm again doesn't
exist in this timeline and so from here
we see the Susan storm using her
abilities blast the defenders off-guard
and when she does in the time that
they're occupied she grabs a Wolverine
and makes the both of them invisible
now from here Wolverine the normal
version of Wolverine and Susan storm try
to escape but as the normal version of
Wolverine explains it
this isn't going to do them any real
good and the reason why is because the
alternate reality version of Wolverine
is most likely like the normal version
and if that's the case then when
Wolverine picks up a scent he never
loses it and so it's going to be highly
unlikely that the normal version of
Wolverine and Susan storm are going to
be able to successfully get away from
the alternate reality version of
Wolverine and the defenders and of
course this is what we see we see that
almost immediately after they get away
that they're pursued and tracked down by
the defenders and what we see is this
conflict taking place we see this really
interesting kind of situation where
Susan storm and the normal version of
Wolverine are doing the best they can to
hold off the defenders but in the end
they're unsuccessful they're not
actually able to get away and so for the
most part they're they're taken away
they're held captive by the defenders
and taken back to presumably maybe one
of the the shield helicarriers or
perhaps even the the main shield base
but what's also very interesting is we
get some in-depth
maybe some insight into the defenders in
the sense that they again don't really
know what's going on here
now initially the idea is they're saying
they don't want to talk to him whoever
him is but of course Doctor Strange says
that most likely they're going to need
to they're going to have to talk to him
and what we learn is that the hem
they're referring to is actually Tony
Stark and that this version of Tony
Stark differs vastly to the normal
version of Tony Stark in the sense that
this one appears to be some amalgamation
of cybernetics and
normal humanoid appearances indicating
that perhaps he's a robot or perhaps
he's simply some kind of cyborg so with
age of Ultron issue number eight we get
this really really really cool story
where we learn what it was that it
happened after the death of Hank Pym
that had caused this reality to take
place now for those of you guys who were
unfamiliar with the idea of branch
universe theory in Marvel Comics and in
comic books as a whole I would advise
you guys to either go back and watch my
video on how alternate realities
function or to go watch Betty's video on
alternate realities and how they form
within both the DC and Marvel because
that's going to be pretty important for
you guys to understand in order to
really be able to get a good grasp on
how this works but what we see as we
start this issue with is that Tony Stark
has taken the memories of both Wolverine
and Susan storm and converted them into
images something that he can physically
look at now we don't know for example
how he's able to do this but what we do
know is that whatever technology is
being used by him at this time is far
more advanced than the technology that
exists in the normal earth-616 universe
indicating to us that perhaps something
took place whereby technology had to be
sped up but what we see going on is that
while Tony Stark is analyzing these
memories he's not necessarily analyzing
them on his own of course he's using
Jarvis but he's also made these memories
in the form of images because he's
enlisted the aid of Emma Frost and
Professor Charles Xavier and what this
tells us is that both of these
individuals exist within this alternate
reality now of course Emma Frost and
Charles Xavier were largely tied to the
x-men but we don't know if the x-men
even exist at this point of course we
know that Cyclops who is using the
codename Cable is a part of the
defenders which tells us that perhaps
the x-men maybe fell apart they went
away or perhaps they were never even
formed by Professor Charles Xavier and
Emma Frost all we know is that at this
point they've more or less just come
together to work for for Tony Stark and
what Tony Stark asks them is whether or
not these memories could have been
duplicated whether or not they could
have been falsely implanted perhaps the
by Morgana lafay no Morgana lafay again
is a villain that we haven't got to yet
in our discussions on this YouTube
channel but for those of you guys who
are familiar
with Hollywood villains you know that
Morgana LeFay is not necessarily a major
villain in the sense that she goes
against a wide array of different teams
the x-men the Avengers and so on
she's largely a villain of Doctor Doom
of the defenders and of a Spider Woman
but for this story Marvel's elevated her
to a major villain but what we see Emma
Frost and Charles Xavier saying is that
even if Morgana lafay somehow had a hand
in this there is no possible way she
could have implanted these memories into
the minds of Susan storm and one will
reign and allowed them to see two
different things at the same time and
interpret them different ways that it's
just not possible and then she does have
that kind of magic if she does have that
kind of power at her disposal then
perhaps she's far more powerful than any
of them had previously thought but again
Tony Stark's a little reluctant here
Tony Stark's a little hesitant to
believe that they come from an alternate
reality but if that's the case if they
do come from an alternate reality if
they do hail from a different dimension
and that Wolverine
or Susan storm or somebody had done
something to alter the course of reality
then as far as Tony Stark is concerned
they've somehow managed to break time
and so again the idea here is that the
the normal I'm sorry the alternate
version of Wolverine wants to
interrogate the normal work version of
Wolverine and Tony Stark says no Tony
Stark says this is not going to happen
not only that he also tells Xavier to
send the defenders away which tells us
that maybe there's trouble in paradise
here that things are not necessarily on
a I guess a solid foundation between the
defenders and Tony Stark that maybe
there's an uneasy alliance here that
perhaps they were even coerced into
undertaking this role in addition Emma
Frost asked the question as to whether
or not she should wipe the memories of
this current event from the minds of the
defenders and what Charles Xavier does
here is he indicates to us that while
this is an alternate reality that his
mindset and his belief systems still
remain the same in the fact that he
tells Emma Frost that he doesn't like
that kind of abuse of power he doesn't
like people using their powers to
manipulate the minds of others or to use
their powers on others against their
will and so what Tony Stark does is he
tells Jarvis to pull up the security
footage from from Hank PIMs murder from
here we switched to Wolverine and
Wolverines being interrogated by Tony
Stark so presumably this takes place
perhaps some time after Tony Stark had
looked at the footage and what Tony
Stark tells Wolverine is that for the
longest time they had believed that Hank
Pym had been murdered by a scroll in
addition Wolverine asked Tony Stark what
it is that that happened to him why it
is that half his body is gone and what
what Tony Stark says is that at some
point in the past after the death of
Hank Pym that the Avengers had split
apart that there was a war between
Latveria the home of Doctor Doom and
Asgard the home of Thor but that after
this conflict after this this war had
taken place that Thor had vanished and
that he hadn't been seen since in
addition we learned that Morgana lafay
has conquered half of the world and most
of Europe indicating that whatever kind
of forces she has must be forces of
incredible magnitude what we also find
out is that the Avengers had broken up
after the the death of Hank Pym and that
magic had somehow won over technology
and that Asgard in addition to Thor had
turned their back on the on the planet
Earth entirely and so as Tony Stark puts
that Wolverine had completely and
totally broken the world by the actions
or by committing the action of killing
Hank Pym from here we transition to
Susan storm and Susan storm is being
held in some kind of some kind of giant
square room and she doesn't really know
where she is she's trying to call for
someone to come in and talk to her but
nobody answers and so what she does is
she uses her powers to create force
fields to somehow make a force field
within the handcuffs that are used to
bind her hands and by using her force
field she's able to destroy these these
restraints and able to escape at this
point we switch back to wool vein and
wolverine asks again what it is that's
going on here if he's under arrest if
he's allowed to go but what tony stark
asked wolverine if it is if he knows
what the butterfly effect is does he
know what it means when one act takes
place that influences a multitude of
other acts and what wolverine says is
that he doesn't think he did anything
wrong here that hank pym created a robot
and because he created Ultron that the
world had been left to burn and so for
him
he done the right thing here but Tony
Stark combats this by saying that it
wasn't necessarily a robot that it was
artificial intelligence it was a
singular mind that was designed to
capitalize on his own intelligence and
to continually improve itself then he
asked Wolverine if he ever did anything
to try to talk him out of this if he
ever tried to get him to see the error
of his ways and Wolverine says that he
tried but inevitably he knew that it
would have failed and the reason why
it's because for people like Hank Pym
and Tony Stark and Reed Richards that is
some kind of a religion that once they
realized they can do something that they
can somehow engage into a new new for
array of technology that they have to do
it that they can't not do it and so he
felt as though again killing Hank Pym
was his only option and so Tony Stark
who looks at Wolverine and asked him if
he believes he's some kind of a selfish
hero that he somehow saved the world and
of course Wolverine says that he's not
necessarily proud of it but that he
thinks he did the right thing and Tony
Stark says that if Wolverine believes
that this current reality is better than
the one that Wolverine came from then
Wolverine is a fool and what this means
for the most part is far is our
interpretation goes is that even if the
even if Ultron had somehow managed to
eradicate the past even if somehow he
managed to eliminate all these forces
into the timeline that Wolverine had
came from when they jumped into the past
that there was still the possibility
that Wolverine that Ultron could have
been stopped there was still the
possibility they could have done
something to change things but with this
reality it seems as though the world is
on the brink of its self-destruction and
so there's really no way to get out of
this circumstance from here we
transition to one of the helicarrier's
along with Colonel America Hank I'm
sorry Jim Van Dyne and others and for
the most part again defenders have band
together because they want to know what
is it what it is us taking place you
want to know what's going on here
indicating that of course the defenders
are being kept in the dark by the forces
of Tony Stark and various other
individuals and they're not necessarily
previewed to the kind of information
that would normally be done in the
normal reality when we would see that
the Avengers would share information
with shield
in addition Emma Frost arrives here and
Emma Frost held the defenders that
they've been ordered to go back to their
to their INR to their rest of relaxation
time or to do whatever it is they do
when they haven't been called on for a
mission what we see is that for the most
part I guess the thing Ben Grimm wants
to know what's going on with Susan storm
he wants to know why it is as Susan
storm is here he wants to know why it is
that presumably she's alive if it is the
real her and again as far as Wolverine
was able to detect using his senses it
was in fact the real Susan storm is so
Ben Grimm is very confused here in
addition the defenders are very upset at
the fact that for the most part they're
being left in the dark that they're
being held out on information that they
consider to be important and so what Ben
Grimm does is he initially goes and I
guess passes by Emma Frost and attempts
to enter the Helicarrier to find out
what's taking place but Emma Frost tries
to grab him and stop him and tell him
that if she if he can continues if he
keeps moving and doing what he's doing
that she's going to revert his mind back
to a primitive state from here Doctor
Strange who appears to be the leader of
the defender steps in and says that if
Emma Frost does anything like that that
he'll use his powers on her as she's
never to touch a member of the defenders
and given the fact that she's displayed
such an arrogance against one of his
members and once the one of the members
of the defenders he tells the thing Ben
Grimm that he's okay with his choice and
that Ben Grimm can now undergo the task
of trying to find out what's going on
with with Susan storm at this point we
transitioned back to Ironman and to a
Wolverine and again Tony Stark is
continuing to interrogate Wolverine and
what he does here is he tells Wolverine
there was another choice that could have
been made here there was a third
decision
Wolverine had a multitude of
opportunities in front of him but he
didn't think of the most rational one he
simply just thought of the only thing
that he knew which was to kill Hank Pym
what Tony Stark says is that he that
Wolverine could have told Hank Pym about
what was gonna happen and they could
have devised a time-release virus that
this virus at the right moment could
have been activated by Hank Pym and
could have been used to kill Ultron but
instead Wolverine decided to kill Hank
Pym what we also see is that while this
interrogation is taking place that the
thing Ben Grimm and the remainder of the
defenders are breaking in to the to the
Helicarrier and trying to find Susan
storm and so for the most part we see
these two situations going on
same time we see that Tony Stark is for
the most part chastising Wolverine of
the over the fact that he broke time
that time is not some kind of absolute
construct but it's not some kind of
absolute thing the time has
ramifications that met a manipulating
time that messing the time can cause a
lot more problems than people had
initially thought and as we transition
back to the thing Ben Grimm we see that
of course they they appear to be able to
break into the the holding cell
containing Susan storm at this point
because the holding cell has been broken
the I guess Jarvis comes in and tells
Tony Stark that they're under lockdown
and Tony Stark begins to realize or
begins to believe that maybe this is
again some kind of trick by Morgana
lafha and Wolverine is surprised to see
the Morgana lafha is even in the
discussion here that Morgana lafay is
considered a threat by anybody and as
the door I guess is a the defenders
hover around the door and begin to break
into it when they get in they realize
that the room is empty but Wolverine
says that Susan storm was just here that
her scent is very very strong at this
point the door slams shut behind him and
what we learn is that Susan storm was in
the room when they at first entered but
she had made herself invisible and she
had taken their the the opportunity
they're surprised at believing she was
gone to sneak out and then shut the door
behind her effectively leaving Cyclops
the thing and Wolverine trapped inside
of this room from here we again
transitioned back to Tony Stark and Tony
Stark has left the interrogation room of
Wolverine and is now pursuing Susan
storm and again while he doesn't
necessarily believe this may be a
attempt by Morgana lafay to infiltrate
shield or to infiltrate what passes for
shield and this alternate reality he
does believe this Susan storm doesn't
need to be there and so the defenders go
to the aid of Susan storm to a degree
but Tony Stark is also attending to kill
Susan storm but before anybody can
really do anything in terms of their a
defense of either against or for Susan
storm there's a massive flash of light
in the sky and as the light begins to
dissipate as things begin to come into I
guess come into clarity we learn that
out of this portal in the sky come the
forces of Morgana lafha along with an
entire host of doom bots at this point
the defenders jump into action and the
defenders do what they can to try to
hold off the forces of Morgana LeFay but
again for the most part they are
absolutely helpless against such
overwhelming odds but again we see that
we transition back and forth between
both the bit the thing Ben Grimm Cyclops
and Wolverine has her trapped in the
room Tony Stark as he's trying to kill
Susan storm as well as the defenders who
were fighting out in in the open against
the doombots and Tony Stark once he
arrives demands that all of the drones
at his disposal be used to combat the
forces of Morgan Morgan Olaf a so for
the most part he's abandoned this
attempt to kill Susan storm and is
trying to keep Morgan Olaf a from
conquering this entire area again we see
that the defenders are trying to do what
they can to hold her off but for the
most part they're unsuccessful here due
to the fact that the doombots that she
has at her disposal are magically
enchanted given her ability to
manipulate magic and sorcery but also
because there's just so many of them and
so as as Tony Stark
is battling Morgana love faith he tells
her that he thought it was a very
interesting trick that she had attempted
to have a clone or perhaps some kind of
copy of Wolverine and Susan storm enter
the Helicarrier an attempt to subvert
them from within but Morgana LaFace says
she doesn't nobody's talking about that
she has no idea what it is that he means
when he says this but tells him to turn
around and when Tony Stark turns around
he realizes that two of the
helicarrier's are crashing into one
another and themselves crashing into New
York City below from here we're gonna
bring this story to an amen' the next
issue we'll see what happens with the
fallout of this conflict when both of
these helicarriers are crashing into the
city as well as what presumably happens
between the normal and the alternate
versions of wolf brain and how
everything appears to possibly go back
to normal
so with age of Ultron issue number nine
we're going to get this sort of piecing
together of events this idea of the
alternate road that Wolverine could have
taken had he actually decided to use the
advice that was given to him by Tony
Stark in the alternate reality now
before we get too far into the story I'm
gonna let you guys know ahead of time
this story's gonna get confusing as [ __ ]
so I'm gonna do what I can to try to try
to explain it as best I can to keep it
as simple as possible so what we see as
we start this story is that for the most
part the helicarriers have already
crashed into New York City and New York
City is almost totally destroyed the
immediate vicinity where the Helicarrier
crashed is virtually in shambles but in
addition to this almost all the
superheroes the defenders and most
everybody who is part of this conflict
is dead but as we see Wolverine is one
of the only individuals who's able to
escape and he's able to get out of the
rubble from here we switched to about
five days later and Wolverines leg has
completely healed itself
and easy to repair as he prepares to to
walk away to move away he's attacked by
a couple doombots indicating to us that
over the course of this five days that
Morgana lafay has successfully been able
to take over this half of the world and
so most likely she takes over the entire
world now we don't really know what
happens with her after this we don't
know if she even survived the conflict
or if she was killed in the process but
as things begin to move forward and we
see that of course Wolverine is able to
easily overpower and destroy these
doombots due to of course his adamantium
claws in addition to his accelerated
healing factor and so for the most part
the do bots aren't really able to do
much against him but after he's able to
successfully destroy the doom bots he
again continues to walk away but he's
grabbed by Tony Stark
and Tony Stark asks him he asked him
whether or not a person like Hank Hamm
could make so much of a difference if he
was his existence would really be able
to change the world entirely to make it
something other than what it is right
now and so he tells Wolverine that he
knows he's going to try to travel back
in time and to stop himself from killing
Hank Pym he knows he's going to try to
fix his mistake but that he can't do
that
and the reason why is because time again
is not this indestructible thing time is
not this absolute construct time as he
explains it is a living organism that
while it doesn't necessarily have
sentience it doesn't really walk around
and move around the time is part of
everything it's part of all life and
that it can bend and it can break and
that if Wolverine keeps manipulating
time too much that he'll he'll tear it
and he'll destroy time entirely and the
question would become what would happen
if time didn't exist anymore what would
happen if it came to an end because the
individuals who would be affected here
would not just be Wolverine and Tony
Stark and the other earthbound heroes
that it would be the universe as a whole
indicating to us that is quite possible
that the ramifications of Wolverines
actions could have an impact on not just
this universe but other universes as
well which of course is something we
will see in that Angela will be brought
to this universe and that Galactus will
be affected by Wolverines actions as
well from here we transition back to the
point in which Wolverine had initially
encountered Hank Pym and attempted to
kill him and for the sake of this
discussion and what's going to be coming
up we're gonna be referring to the
Wolverine that's wearing gray as the
normal Wolverine and the Wolverine
that's wearing his old uniform as the
classic Wolverine and again I know this
is a little confusing but once the video
begins to wrap up it'll all make sense
and it'll all tie together but again the
normal version of Wolverine has not
killed Hank Pym yet and so of course
he's telling Hank Pym the same thing
that he had told him that he's
transitioning back to the same moment
when he says that Hank Pym had done some
great things in the world that Hank Pym
had done what he could but that in the
end the actions of Hank Pym wiping out
or I guess creating Ultron who in turn
wiped out all life on the planet this is
something that just cannot be ignored
and so again wolverine prepares to kill
Hank Pym from here we transitioned back
to Susan storm who's standing out by the
car and soon as the storm is debating
with herself she's asking what it is
she's doing out here why is it that
she's simply just waiting she says she
can't let this happen but that the needs
of her friends are also the needs of her
own and so the question that she's
debating with herself is the same debate
that her and Wolverine had previously
gotten into
where the issue was which one is more
important than needs of the mini or what
it is that she thinks is right
but before she's able to take any action
she's presumably knocked out by somebody
at this point we transitioned back to
the normal Wolverine as he's fighting
and attempting to kill Hank him but
again before he's able to engage too
much further before he's able to
actually deal a killing blow to hank pym
somebody yell stop and when they turn
around we see the Wolverine that had
initially jumped forward and killed Hank
him the first time and again we're gonna
refer to him as classic Wolverine and
classic Wolverine tells normal Wolverine
that this isn't going to work that
hain't him dying is not going to fix the
problem that when Hank him dies that his
creates a reality that's just as bad if
not worse than the reality that the
normal Wolverine had left in an attempt
to kill Hank Pym in order to fix it and
what a normal Wolverine believes is that
perhaps this is some kind of a ruse that
perhaps this is some kind of a joke but
classic will rain tells a normal
Wolverine to stand down he says that
this is not some kind of a ruse so this
is him coming to him to try to tell him
what it is this going to happen what it
is this going to take place if he
engages in this action classic Wolverine
also tells Hank Pym that this is exactly
what it looks like
that moon Wolverine had become there in
an attempt to kill him and that with his
death he had hoped that Ultron by virtue
of having never been created would cease
to exist and that the future would be
fixed but normal Wolverine asks classic
Wolverine who it was that sent him if it
was Captain America if perhaps he's
there on Ultron's orders but classic
Wolverine tells normal Wolverine that
it's the outfit that he's currently
wearing is the only outfit that was
brought with him but that the whole
purpose of him being here is to try to
keep normal Wolverine from killing Hank
Pym and what classic Wolverine does is
he gives normal Wolverine a I guess a
some kind of proof that he is really
Wolverine he simply just tells him 1928
Sharleen Baumgartner and this seems to
be some kind of proof that seems to be
some kind of evidence to indicate that
classic Wolverine is really Wolverine
and that the two of them are existing in
the same time and so no more rain begins
to listen he begins to pay attention to
what it is that's going on and he asked
classic Wolverine what it is that they
should do
and of course he offers a few
suggestions he says maybe they should
kill him another time maybe they should
go back and kill him as a baby but for
the most part classic Wolverine says no
he says that hank pym has to exist that
hank pym has to live that he has to
create Ultron and he says that Tony
Stark had given him some kind of an idea
something about possibly creating a
virus but for the most part Hank Pym is
very shocked to see all of this taking
place he's amazed to know that that this
is the Wolverine knows who Tony Stark is
he's amazed to know that he of course is
an Avenger when he claims to have been
an Avenger it's really interesting for
Hank Pym to watch this thing unfold to
learn the time-travel does exist and for
the most part we see that Hank Pym says
ok he says that if the future comes to a
very dark point if a future needed is
led to a place where by Ultron is able
to conquer the world then he simply
won't make Ultron but classic Wolverine
says no he says that everything that has
ever happened up until the point when he
first went back in time has to happen
that all those things have to take place
otherwise the universe could end up
where the all of reality could end up in
a much worse place than it is right now
and so again the question is asked does
it mean that Ultron has to be created
and that if Ultron is going to mop the
floor with them then why should Hank Pym
create Ultron in the first place but
again the classic Wolverine says that
some kind of time release virus can be
installed in Ultron some kind of time
release virus can be made so that when
Ultron attempts to take over the world
the first time that this virus can be
activated and that Ultron won't actually
come to power but for the most part we
again see both of these Wolverines
debating with one another we see both of
these Wolverines again trying to come to
terms normal wolverine still wants to
kill Hank Pym but classic will reign is
continuing you to try to convince him
that killing Hank Pym will not fix the
world's problems that it will not make
things better again we see Hank Pym
saying that he knows what he has to do
that for the most part he's not prepared
about what about what will take place he
knows that if Ultron being created is
going to lead to Ultron evolving itself
and by virtue of evolving itself leading
multiple incursions against the Avengers
and against the planet Earth and now
they'll know
but again normal Wolfer absolute classic
Wolverine says that this won't work that
that Hank pen has to continue the
timeline has to continue as if
everything had simply just functioned
the way it always did and Hank Pym asks
how he says how is he supposed to do
this house is supposed to achieve and at
this point Susan storm chimes in and
Susan storm says he's going to have to
make himself forget now this would be
something that'll actually happen
outside of Hank Pym it will happen
because of something he doesn't control
but for the most part Hank Pym is again
surprised to see Susan storm because in
his time and the 1960 Susan storm is
much younger but again Susan storm says
that for the most part they should bring
Reed Richards in on this they should get
a hold of Reed Richards in their time
because what they can do is explain to
that version of Reed Richards what it is
has taken place and Reed Richards can
help them come to terms with what's
going on help them figure out a way to
solve things but the classic Wolverine
says no classic Wolverine says that
nobody else can know about this because
if anybody else is aware of this and no
intern be affected by the actions here
and this has to be a self-contained
situation in order to keep the timeline
functioning the way that it always has
and so what Hank Pym does is he asked
the question how was this supposed to
happen he asked how is it that he is
supposed to create Ultron knowing that
Ultron is going to challenge and attempt
to defeat the Avengers on multiple
occasions possibly leading to a
situation whereby Ultron is going to
take over the world how can he do this
without somehow doing anything to try to
stop Ultron along the way aside from
creating a Time time-related virus a
time-released virus but for the most
part we don't see any kind of answer
that's given to him because what we do
is we transition back to Antarctica back
to the Savage Land whereby we have the
classic Wolverine the one who initially
traveled in time in the first place the
normal Wolverine who was the version
that classic Wolverine had encountered
as he traveled back to try to stop
himself from killing Hank Pym and of
course Susan storm and what Susan storm
asks is are they both really going to
come back here are they both really
going to go back to the future and what
a classic Wolverine says is no he simply
tells her to give them a minute and so
as the two of them enter the cave
classic Wolverine tells normal Wolverine
that he's seen too many things that he's
seen what happens when hank pym dies
that he's seen all these future outcomes
he's seen what happens when Morgana
lafay takes over the world and then
these are memories that he just can't
live with that he doesn't want to
continue with and so what he does is he
tells normal Wolverine to kill him and
so from here we transition back to Susan
storm and as a normal Wolverine or I
guess the only Wolverine now is walking
out we get this kind of transition we
get this kind of situation where we see
that of course who's in storm is
surprised to see that he killed the
other version of himself but we also see
that hank pym is continuing to work on
ultron and for the most part hank pym is
haunted by this hank pym is really
affected by the idea that he is
consciously creating a robot that could
potentially take over the world and the
question that Susan storm asks is what
happens what happens if hank pym
creating a time-release virus is beyond
his abilities what happens if you create
the time-release virus and Ultron but
somewhere along the way Ultron becomes
conscious of it and decides to correct
it no one really knows what would go on
here a lot of things are being left off
but left up to chance but as a story
begins to come to an end as this comic
begins to come to an end we're left with
Ultron as he's activating itself for the
first time and calling Hank Pym his
daddy
so with age of Ultron issue number 10 we
get the conclusion to this event but
what we also get is the results of what
happened with Wolverine tampering with
time of what happened when Wolverine had
effectively broken time and as we start
this story we see that a package is
delivered to hate him around the time
that Holtz wrong Ultron attempts to take
over the world about some months before
the forces of the Avengers successfully
or I guess I encounter Ultron when he's
really conform oast part he doesn't know
who deliver this package although is
revealed to us to be Susan storm but
when he opens it up it's simply
something or a device of some kind of
place videos that simply says play me on
it and when he plays it it's a video of
himself from the past and what he tells
his future self is that there's a reason
why he doesn't remember making this
video that he had been made to forget
now we know that the reason why he had
forgotten is making this video or the
events around it was because Ultron had
modified his memories when Hank hem
first first created Ultron and of course
this was something that was explained to
us way back in the Avengers comics when
the vision had first appeared Marvel had
simply just used this as an explanation
to why it is that Hank Pym doesn't
remember making this video but what his
past self says is that of all the things
that they had screwed up of all the
things all the mistakes they had ever
made that creating Ultron was the worst
one that because of this Ultron is going
to enact a set of actions a set of
circumstances that is going to lead to
almost the end of the world as far as
they know and so what he says is that
Hank Pym is going to have to do
something that he's getting ready to
tell him that he's going to have to
start a project that is going to
effectively allow him to defeat Ultron
at this point we jump back to the point
in which Ultron first reawakens when he
first arrives and of course the Avengers
are doing what they can to combat Ultron
to try to bring an end to Ultron but
again because of the power that Ultron
possesses because of the sheer strength
that he has and his adamantium physique
or as adamantium body he's able to
easily take on the Avengers unable to
easily overpower almost all of them but
in addition to this Ultron realizes that
something's going on here that
something's taking place now initially
the idea
is that he thinks that perhaps and maybe
somebody tied into Tony Stark but he
also believes that Hank Pam has
something to do with this and as they're
fighting the questions being asked is
hank pym doing it is hank pym working on
whatever it is he's working on and hank
pym says yes hank pym says that he's
still loading something now we're
presuming that this is the virus that
hank pym and created although we don't
know if that's an absolute fact
but again hank pym says that ultron is
for the most part fighting this that
he's going to figure out what's going on
and when he does he's going to shut it
down
and so he says of the Avengers have to
do something they had to find some way
to stall him and so as the Avengers are
fighting a fighting Ultron Ultron is
learning what's taking place of course
we see that Abigail brand with sword is
calling in reinforcements but for the
most part again Ultron is figuring out
what's taking place he realizes that a
Hank Pym is involved in this somehow
that Hank Pym is doing something to
alter his coding to alter his
programming and Ultron deduce is that
what Hank Pym is trying to do is to shut
him down to deprogram him by
reprogramming and this is what Ultron's
says Ultron says that for the most part
this isn't going to work that he is
effectively closing every backdoor that
Hank Pym opens that he is correcting
Hank Pym code as it's being uploaded to
Ultron and so again Ultron gets mad
about this Ultron feels insulted by the
fact that Hank Pym would try something
as basic as more or less creating a
trojan backdoor in Ultron's programming
and so what Ultron's says here is that
for the most part he believes that it's
time for humanity's existence to come to
an end that humanity doesn't serve a
purpose that the Avengers serve no
purpose and that he's going to
effectively shut everybody down he's
going to kill them all and he is
presumably going to take over the world
but at this point what we see is that
whatever it is that Hank Pym had done
appears to have been successful when
Ultron begins to spaz a little bit and
then all of a sudden completely shuts
down and so what we get is this
explanation from Hank hem hem hem says
that what he had done what he created
and Ultron was more or less of a ruse it
was a trick
he had effectively tried to create a
backdoor
Ultron's programming and Ultron sensing
this backdoor attempted to shut it down
but when he did it activated a
subroutine that had already been created
by Hank Pym when he first created Ultron
and when the subroutine was activated it
created a self-replicating virus that
shut Ultron down but by the time that
Ultron had realized what this virus was
it was too late and he was seconds away
from from shutting down entirely and so
for the most part again the question is
asked here bye-bye Iron Man by Tony
Stark is how was it that Hank Pym knew
this how he knew that something like
that needed to be done how he knew that
something like that needed to be done at
this particular moment in time but Hank
Pym for the most part doesn't answer him
from here we switched back to a pseudo
storm as she is traveling with Wolverine
back to the Baxter building and
Wolverine tells her to enjoy her life to
enjoy spending time with her family to
make sure her family loves her and as of
course the two begin to part ways
there's some kind of a massive shake
within the city of New York and of
course we see multiple variations of
Wolverine in fact almost every major
alternate reality of Wolverine appearing
of course we see old man Logan among
others we also see the same thing with
Iron Man and for the most part we don't
really know what's taking place here we
don't know what's going on here all we
really know is that perhaps something is
going on that's caused a backlash maybe
a kind of blowback as a result of
Wolverine manipulating reality at this
point we jump to two beasts - Hank McCoy
along with Tony Stark and I believe Reed
Richards I'm sorry Hank Pym and the
question that's being asked here is
what's happened what's going on and so
what what Tony Stark more or less
guesses is that time has been broken
that the space-time Continuum's been
broken by Wolverine and for the most
part Hank Pym cataluña capitalizes on
this Hank Pym says that his guess is
that because Wolverine had up had
continually jumped back and forward in
time because he had repeatedly abused
time that he had more or less I guess
torn the space-time continuum and that
again no one really knows what's going
to take place no one knows what kind of
other
realities may be affected and at this
point we switched to the ultimate
universe with Miles Morales as
spider-man and as he's figuring out his
powers as he's learning and beginning to
become undertake the role of spider-man
again there's some kind of massive flash
in the sky and when he looks up he sees
the silhouette of Galactus but what we
also see and quite possibly more
important than this is the arrival of
Angela into the Marvel Universe with
that being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and let me know what you guys thought
about this age of Ultron series if it
was something that you guys really
really enjoyed and if you did we'll
definitely try to do more like it with
that being said I will catch you guys
later peace
[Music]